all those who value freedom and justice
who cherish it is strongly as we
ukrainians in all our cities in each and
every family I hope my words of respect
and gratitude resonate in each American
Heart
madam
vice president
I thank you for your efforts in helping
Ukraine
Madam speaker
you bravely visited Ukraine during the
full-fledged War
thank you very much great honor thank
you
great privilege to be here
dear members of the Congress
representatives of both parties
who also visited Keith
esteemed congressman and senators from
both parties
who will visit Ukraine
I'm sure in the future dear
representatives of diaspora
[Applause]
present in this chamber and spread
across the country dear journalists
it's a great honor for me to be at the
U.S Congress and speak to you and all
Americans
against
All Odds and doom and gloom
scenarios Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and Kicking
[Applause]
thank you
and it gives me good reason to share
with you our first
first joint Victory we defeated Russia
in the battle for minds of the world
we have no fear
nor should anyone in the world have it
Ukraine's gained this Victory and it
gives us courage which inspires the
entire world
Americans gained this Victory and that's
why you have succeeded in uniting the
global Community to protect freedom
and international law
Europeans gained this Victory and that's
why Europe is now stronger and more
independent than never
the Russian tyranny
has lost control over us
[Applause]
and it will never influence our minds
again yet we have to do whatever it
takes to ensure that countries of the
global South also gain such victory
I know one more I think very important
thing
the Russians will stand a chance to be
free only when
they defeat the Kremlin in their minds
yet
the battle continues and we have to
defeat the Kremlin on the battlefield
yes
these battles not only for the territory
for this or another part of Europe the
battle is not only for Life freedom and
security of ukrainians or any other
nation which Russia attempts to conquer
this struggle will Define in what world
our children and grandchildren will live
and then they are children and
grandchildren it will define whether it
will be a democracy of ukrainians and
for Americans for all
this battle cannot be frozen
or postponed it cannot be
ignored hoping that the ocean or
something else will provide a protection
from the United States to China
from Europe to Latin America and from
Africa to Australia the world is too
interconnected and interdependent to
allow someone to stay aside and at the
same time to feel safe when such a
battle continues
our two Nations
are allies in this battle
and next year will be a turning point I
know it the point when Ukrainian courage
and American resolve must guarantee the
future of our common Freedom the freedom
of people who stand for their values
foreign
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Americans yesterday
before coming
here
to Washington DC I was at the front line
in our stronghold in the east of Ukraine
in the dunbas
the Russian military and missionaries
have been taking back non-stop since May
there have been taking a day and night
but stands
last year
last year 70 000 people lived there in
Bachman in this city and now only few
civilians stay every inch of that land
is sucked in blood roaring guns sound
every hour
trenches in the donbass change hands
several times a day
in Fierce combat and even hand fighting
but the Ukrainian donbass stands
Russians
Russians use everything everything they
have against bhagavat and other
our beautiful cities
the occupiers have a significant
advantage in artillery they have an
advantage in ammunition they have much
more missiles and planes
than we ever had as it's true but our
Defense Forces stand
[Applause]
and we
and and we all are proud of them
the Russians tactic is primitive
they burn down and destroy everything
they see
they sent thugs to the front lines they
sent convicts to the war
they threw everything against us similar
to the other tyranny which is in the
Battle of The Balch
through everything it had again the Free
World just like the brave American
soldiers which held their lines and
fought back Hitler's forces during the
Christmas of 1944 Brave Ukrainian
soldiers are doing the same to Putin's
forces this Christmas
foreign
Ukraine holds its lines and Will Never
Surrender
so so here is the front line The Tyranny
which has no lack of Cruelty again the
lives of free people
and your support is crucial not just to
stand in such fight but to get to the
turning point to win on the battlefield
we have artillery yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly I'm not
really
to ensure
is not just a stronghold that holds back
the Russian army but for the Russian
army to completely pull out more cannons
and shells are needed if so just like
the Battle of Saratoga the fight for
Bachman will change the trajectory of
our war for independence and for freedom
if your Patriots
stop
the Russian Terror against our cities it
will let Ukrainian Petros work to the
full to defend our freedom
when Russia
when Russia cannot reach our cities but
it's artillery it tries to destroy them
with missile attacks more than that
Russia found an ally in this
in this genocidal policy Iran
Iranian deadly drones sent to Russia in
hundreds and hundreds became a threat to
our critical infrastructure
that is how one terrorist has found the
other
it is just a matter of time when they
will strike against your other allies if
we do not stop them now we must do it
I believe
I believe there should be no taboose
between us in our alliance Ukraine never
asked the American soldiers to fight on
our land instead of us
I assure you that Ukrainian soldiers can
perfectly operate American tanks
and plans themselves
foreign
National Financial assistant is also
critically important and I would like to
thank you thank you very much thank you
for both Financial packages you have
already provided us with and the ones
you may be willing to decide on your
money is not charity
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy that we handle in
the most responsible way
foreign
Russia could stop its aggression
really if it wanted to but you can speed
up our victory
I know it
and eat and it will prove to any
potential aggressor that no one can
succeeded in breaking national borders
no one committing atrocities and
reigning over people against their will
it would be Nave to wait for steps
towards peace from Russia which enjoys
being a terrorist state
Russians are still poisoned by the
Kremlin
the restoration of international legal
order is our Joint Task we need peace
yes Ukraine has already offered
proposals which I just discussed with
President Biden our peace formula 10
points which should and must be
implemented for our joint security
guaranteed for decades ahead and the
summit which can be held I'm glad to
shred that President Biden supported our
peace initiative today each of you
ladies and gentlemen can assist in the
implementation to ensure that America's
leadership remains solid
by camera
and bipartisan
thank you
you can strengthen sanctions to make
Russia feel how ruinous its aggression
truly is
it is in your power really to help us
bring to Justice everyone who started
this unprovoked and criminal War let's
do it
LED terrorists
let the terrorists stay be held
responsible for its Terror and
aggression and compensate all losses
done by this war that the world see that
the United States are here
ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen Americans in two
days
we will
celebrate
Christmas
maybe candle it
not because it's more romantic now
but because there will not be
will be no electricity
Millions won't have neither hitting nor
running water
all of these will be the result of
Russian missile and drone attacks on our
energy infrastructure
but we do not complain
we do not judge and compare whose life
is easier
your well-being is the product
of your National Security
the result of your struggle for
Independence and your many victories
we ukrainians will also go through our
war of independence and freedom with
dignity and success
foreign
Christmas
celebrate Christmas and even if there is
no electricity Delight of our faith in
ourselves will not be put out
if Russian if Russian missiles attack us
will do our best to protect ourselves
if they attack us with Iranian drones
and our people will have to go to bomb
shelters on Christmas Eve ukrainians
will still sit down at the Holiday table
and cheer up each other
and we don't don't have to know every
every once wish as we know that all of
us millions of ukrainians wish the same
victory
only victory
we already built strong Ukraine with
strong people strong Army Strong
institutions together with you we
develop strong security guarantees for
our country and for entire Europe and
the world together with you and also
together with you will put in
Place everyone who will defy freedom put
in
[Applause]
this will be the basis to protect
democracy in Europe and the world over
now on the special
Christmas time I want to thank you
all of you
I think every American family
which cherishes the warmth of its home
and Wishes the same warmth to other
people
I think President Biden and both parties
at the Senate and the house for your
invaluable assistance
I think your cities and your citizens
who supported Ukraine this year who
hosted our ukrainians our people
who waived our national flags who acted
to help us think thank you all from
everyone who is now at the front line
from everyone who is evading victory
standing here today I recall the words
of the President Franklin
Delano Roosevelt
which has I think so good for this
moment
the American people
in their righteous might
will win through to Absolute victory
the Ukrainian people will win too
absolutely
thank you
I know that everything depends on us on
Ukrainian Armed Forces yet so much
depends on the world so much in the
world depends on you
when I was in Bahamut yesterday our Our
Heroes
gave me the flag
the battle sack the flag of those who
defend Ukraine Europe and the world at
the cost of their lives they asked me to
bring this flag to you to the U.S
Congress to members of the House of
Representatives and Senators whose
decisions can save millions of people
so let these decisions be taken let this
flag stay with you lettuce and gentlemen
this flag is a symbol of our victory in
this war
We Stand we fight and we will win
because we are united Ukraine America
and the entire free world
foreign
if I can the the last thing thank you so
much may God protect our brave troops
and citizens may God forever bless the
United States of America merry Christmas
and happy Victorious New Year
thank you so much
yes there we go
thank you
this flag was flown over the capitol
today in honor of the president's visit
foreign
[Music]
hello
the purpose of the joint
the purpose of the joint
okay now
the purpose of the joint meeting haven't
been completed the chair dictate
declares The Joint meeting of the two
houses now dissolved the house will
continue in recess subject to the call
of the chair
what's up
[Applause]
I'm gonna show this to you